[Applause]
electioneering is in full swing in
Poland the ruling line just as part of
your pis wants to win a third term in
office it would be a first in Polish
Democratic history their slogan save
future for polls
illegal immigration a large number of
people came here not to work but to
benefit from social assistance on the
other hand they also undermine security
but it won't be easy sailing for the
incumbent government to win again the
opposition is hitting at government
spending Refugee numbers and claims of
abuse of power
persuade others so on October 15th we
will vote kachinski out those who made
money from your hard work will simply
have to give it all back but the likely
King makers will be the far-right
confederacia party analysts say their
social media and fresh leadership are
appealing for young and first-time
voters
in addition to the elections polls will
be voting on a referendum consisting of
four important issues illegal says the
opposition but the ruling party says
that is a gauge of what people think on
important
issuesca on state media PISD has
explained the referendum about
privatization the retirement age
immigration and the board offense with
Belarus
they even show the no option to voters a
tactic fiercely opposed by the Civic
platform and others
the referendum will help Law And Justice
party mobilize voters there are no
spending limits on a referendum unlike
electoral campaigns so it can be
sponsored by state-owned or other
institutions which will give the
advantage to the ruling party
critics of the government say it's
diverting attention to issues which are
not on the main discourse Muslims are
less than one percent of the population
and the campaigns are disproportionately
targeted at perceived risks from
migrants and refugees
the political situation in Poland for
Muslims and other minorities is not very
favorable the opposition and the left
approaches more openly
a referendum I
a very sensible idea in my opinion we
won't have to go to the election
commission twice
I've made my decision running a business
in Poland is not easy due to the amount
of taxes
this week's before the Parliamentary
vote people are split and priorities
range from inflation to the economy and
migration to security and early polls
suggest voters are likely to deliver a
divided verdict Poland